alex est dépendance au pyroïd tous les
jours il consomme du dis le guide un
dérivé semi-synthétique de la morphine
prescrit par son médecin en plus de son
traitement de substitution par la
méthadone c'est là qu'on voit que c'est
vraiment la prohibition quand la
consommation difficile parce que quand
je consommais
mes relations avec mes amis étaient pas
très bonne parce que ma vie était juste
centrée là-dessus depuis que je consomme
juste milieu mes relations sont super
bonnes l'approvisionnement plus
sécuritaire sauve des vies mais une
infime proportion des consommateurs il y
a présentement accès alors que la drogue
qui circule dans les rues est plus
contaminée que jamais au Québec en 2021
450 personnes sont mortes de surdose
selon l'Institut national de santé
publique du Québec c'est près de 100
personnes de plus que les décès sur les
rues de la province récemment retraité
de son poste de coordonnateur des
programmes de réduction des méfaits au
ministère de la santé des services
sociaux et chaque routier demande au
gouvernement d'en faire plus ça soit
j'ai l'impression un peu sur ce qui a
déjà été fait puis alors qu'il aurait pu
être possible d'aller plus loin
de prendre davantage de leadership dans
l'approvisionnement sécuritaire en
opioïde par exemple pour contrer
les drones qu'on trouve sur le marché
noir en août 2020 les avocats du
gouvernement fédéral ont reçu
l'instruction d'éviter de lancer des
poursuites criminels pour des délits de
possession simples on assiste donc à une
des judiciarisation de facto partout au
pays sauf au Québec et au
Nouveau-Brunswick qui ne sont pas soumis
aux mêmes directives d'Ottawa depuis 16
directeurs de santé publique du Québec
ainsi que des acteurs du milieu
communautaire presse le gouvernement
trouver des solutions de rechange à la
judiciarisation des personnes pour
possession simples de drogue leur
demande sont restées l'être mortes
questionnés par Radio-Canada le
ministère de la Justice répond que
c'était venu n'est pas envisagée pour
l'instant au Québec on a l'impression
qu'en ce moment peut-être que le
ministère de la Justice ne prend pas
conscience qu'il y a de l'usage de
substances partout et que de le traiter
de façon pragmatique et
honnête ben on devrait avoir des
résultats différents et peut-être à la
fois sauver des vies mais faire en sorte
qu'on ait une société plus juste et
équitable des mesures de réduction des
méfaits qui font en sorte que des
consommateurs comme Alex ne se
retrouvent pas à la rue ici mon Coutu
Radio-Canada Montréal